i introduce you the best sandwiches in
america we
eat the subway always
[Music]
this is mariella hi
this is where she was born
and this is where she lives now
this is how she says hello
this is how she spends her time i do
many things because i cannot stay
stopped
since i
lived in
in the states italian people likes to
refer me ask him help and i like to help
them i like to stay busy
this is how excited she is that we're
gonna give her a special day hi how are
you good morning
i'm ready for manicure today so this
time probably i go with pink
i think it's my phone excuse me
it's okay i'm fortunate to take this
call ciao guardagno berlare sonogon
manicure so these nails make me very
happy i like to take care of people and
sometimes i need that somebody takes
care of me
ah the massage
[Music]
and breathe in
and breathe out
the
massage on the head they feel more
relaxed
this is good
yeah
do it do it
how you feeling fine yeah grazie chloe
[Music]
i want to eat that but it's too big
a lot of stuff here
very
attractive mamma mia
wow
when do i start from here there
oh
this mozzarella
it's very good
i like the name the gabocolo
i want to taste the capricorn by itself
[Music]
we
eat the subway always it is very good i
give it my approval like no no subway i
like so much your sandwiches i had a
great day good food
and manicure done
i'm very happy i finally can finish
[Music]
you